les passions déchaînées par la tentation
du christ et les incendies se sont à
peine éteints que revoici la religieuse
le film de jacques rivette avait fait
scandale il ya plus de vingt ans il
avait même été totalement interdit avant
d'être projeté aux plus de 18 ans il est
maintenant offert à tous les publics
michel pascal images du film qui a
provoqué un scandale retentissant dans
la france des années 60
jacques rivette l'un des pères de la
nouvelle vague s'inspire du roman de
diderot qui raconte d'après des faits
authentiques
comment au xviiie siècle on enfermait au
couvent les fils illégitime et décrit la
vie parfois très libre qui se déroulait
dans les cloîtres l'annnonce du tournage
en 1965 déchaîne la colère des autorités
religieuses qui tentent de l'empêcher
les portes des couvents et des églises
se ferment et l'équipe doit se réfugier
à villeneuve les avignon le film terminé
le secrétaire d'état yvon bourges
l'interdît totalement le 1er avril 66
l'actrice principale anna karina se
souvient de ce climat d'hostilité
je crois que c'est arrivé comme un choc
si violent
toulouse évidemment on était à la lune
vous se [ __ ] des traités de tous les
noms tous les jougs entre les jambes
ok
et c'est un film très très pur et très
beau et c'est un grand classique sud est
hydro c'est comme je pas n'importe qui
la religieuse sort sur les écrans
juillet 1967 assortie d'une interdiction
aux moins de 18 ans interdiction qui
vient seulement d'être levée aujourd'hui
il aura fallu attendre 22 heures